I would like to begin by paying tribute
to all those who have paid with their lives for this
fight for freedom, dignity and
democracy
your country is emerging today as a
model of pluralism and tolerance
in the region the nobel prize awarded to the
national procession has just  to crown this
exceptional course of the Tunisian people
which commands the admiration and respect of
all the economic recovery we thought to
finally launch in 2015 in a
peaceful climate was interrupted by the
heinous terrorist attacks
we felt your
pain deep within ourselves because  these unbearable acts are
committed against all of
humanity jihadist terrorism is a
global phenomenon
but let's beware of false answers
because it would be dangerous to fall into
the trap of all security long
live the Tunisian people thank you
so